F
THE TACTICAL SITUATION ON THE
GROUND.
>> Bret: 20 YEARS ALL THE U.S.
TROOPS ARE NOW OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S A MAJOR MOMENT BUT AS WE
MENTIONED AMERICANS ARE STILL ON
THE GROUND IN HARM'S WAY.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL MOLLIE
HEMINGWAY SENIOR EDITOR AT "THE
FEDERALIST."
JUAN WILLIAMS FOX NEWS ANALYST
AND TREY GOWDY FORMER
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
I WANT GO AROUND THE HORN AND I
MIGHT INTERRUPT YOU IF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE COMES OUT AND
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS MOMENT,
THIS TIME WHAT IT MEANS AND WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST 0
DAYS.
TREY, FIRST TO YOU.
>> 0 YEARS, THE SAME GROUP THAT
WE RAN OFF IS RUNNING
AFGHANISTAN.
WOMEN AND GIRLS ARE STILL SECOND
CLASS CITIZENS.
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES ARE STILL
BEING TARGETED.
JOURNALISTS ARE STILL BEING
BEATEN.
TERRORISTS ARE STILL KILLING
AMERICANS AS EVIDENCED BY THIS
WEEK AND THE BEST WE CAN DO IS
DIPLOMATIC PRESSURE WHICH IS AN
OXYMORON.
>> Bret: YEAH.
MOLLIE?
>> YEAH.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE TALIBAN ARE BIGGER,
STRONGER, THEY CONTROL MORE
TERRITORY, THEY ARE MORE WELL
EQUIPPED AS A MILITARY PRESENCE
AND THAN THEY COULD HAVE DREAMED
OF BEING ON SEPTEMBER 11TH.
PEOPLE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON HOW
INCOMPETENT THIS WITHDRAWAL WAS
AND IT WAS AND CONTRARY TO WHAT
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT HOW IT
COULDN'T HAVE GONE BETTER, IT
WAS A DISASTER.
AND IT WAS HORRIBLE AND AWFUL,
THE LIVES LOST.
AND JUST THE FAILURES THERE.
BUT, REALLY WE NEED TO NOT
FORGET THAT 19 OF THE LAST 20
YEARS OF THIS WAR LED BY WOKE
GENERALS AND POLITICAL LEADERS
WHO MOVED TO NATION BUILDING
INSTEAD OF HAVING PROPER METRICS
FOR SUCCESS OF HOW TO DEFEAT AN
ENEMY, THEY HAVE CAUSED THIS THE
TALIBAN ARE IN A POSITION OF
STRENGTH NOT BECAUSE OF THE LAST
10 DAYS BUT BECAUSE OF THE LAST
19 YEARS.
WE NEED TO NEVER FIGHT A WAR
THIS WAY EVER AGAIN.
IT IS ONE THING TO DO THIS WITH
THE TALIBAN.
IT'S ENTIRELY ANOTHER TO DO IT
WITH A NUCLEAR ADVERSARY, WHICH
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING WE MIGHT BE
FACING IN THE YEARS TO COME.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, JUAN,
OBVIOUSLY, THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO PUT THE BEST FOOT
FORWARD HERE TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THE AIR
LIFT OF GETTING 123,000 OUT.
AND NOT FOCUSING ON TOO MUCH ON
THE AMERICANS ON THE GROUND
SAYING THEY HAVE A PLAN TO GET
THOSE OUT, TALKING ABOUT THE
SUCCESS THAT THEY SEE OF GETTING
U.S. TROOPS OUT.
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF PUSHBACK.
YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT
FROM MOLLIE AND TREY.
HERE'S G.O.P. BACKLASH ABOUT HOW
THIS HAS GONE.
>> WE ARE NOW LESS SAFE.
THE TALIBAN HAS MORE BLACK HAWK
HELICOPTERS THAN AUSTRALIA.
WE HAVE WEAPONIZED THEM.
>> JUST BECAUSE WE DECIDED TO
QUIT FIGHTING DOESN'T MEAN THE
TERRORIST GOES AWAY.
SO THEY ARE STILL OUT THERE.
THEY ARE INVIGORATED AND
EMBOLDENED AND EXCITED ABOUT THE
SUCCESS THEY SEE IN BRINGING
AMERICA TO ITS KNEES.
>> Bret: THOUGHTS ON THAT, JUAN?
>> WELL, I THINK TWO THINGS TO
SAY AND, LET ME JUST SAY I THINK
THIS IS A BOLD HEADLINE DAY FOR
AMERICA THE FOREVER WAR IS OVER.
I THINK WE ACCOMPLISHED THE
GOALS THAT WE SET WHEN WE WENT
IN THERE 20 YEARS AGO.
THAT AFGHANISTAN WAS NOT USED AS
A TERRORIST LAUNCHING SITE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THIS
WAR OVER.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE 13
HEROES WHOSE BODIES CAME HOME
THIS WEEKEND TO DOVER, YOU THINK
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THOSE PEOPLE DIED GOOD CAUSE.
THEY HELPED WITH THIS EVACUATION
TO GET PEOPLE OUT SAFELY.
AND IT'S, YOU KNOW, MORE THAN
100,000 PEOPLE, ALL OF OUR
MILITARY PERSONNEL NOW GONE.
THEY'RE THE LAST PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED IN THIS, YOU KNOW,
AMERICA'S LONGEST WAR, AS YOU
SAID, BRET.
I THINK THE KEY THING IN
RESPONSE TO THOSE QUOTES THAT
YOU JUST PLAYED IS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE TERRORIST THREAT IS
VERY DIFFERENT TODAY THAN IT WAS
20 YEARS AGO.
THE ELEMENT OF SURPRISE IS GONE.
WE HAVE HARDENED OUR TARGETS.
WE HAD NETWORKS OF INTELLIGENCE.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY WHICH WE
HAVE SHOWN OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS TO STRIKE BACK AT
TERRORISTS IN A WAY THAT WE DID
HAVE NOT 20 YEARS AGO.
PRETTY WREATH SOME OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY EXPRESSED
PUBLICLY THAT THOSE MARINES THAT
NAVY CORE CORPSMAN AND U.S.
SOLDIER DIDN'T HAVE TO DIE IT
WAS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THIS WAS HANDLED.
THAT'S THEIR WORDS.
THAT'S THE CRITICISM THAT THOSE
13 DID NOT HAVE TO DIE.
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE CASUALTY
SINCE FEBRUARY OF 2020.
PRIOR TO THIS MOMENT.
NOW, THE SECOND THING IS THAT
THIS TERRORISM THREAT IS REAL NO
MATTER HOW YOU LOOK AT IT SO THE
WAR IN AFGHANISTAN ON THE GROUND
MAY BE OVER AND THE TROOPS MAY
BE OUT OF HARM'S WAY THERE.
BUT, JUAN, YOU KNOW THAT IF IT
POPS UP AND IT LIKELY WILL, IT'S
A WITCH'S BREW OF RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERRORISM THERE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO THERE AND THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE INTELLIGENCE
ASSETS DRY UP WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE SOME ASPECT OF GROUND
PRESENCE.
>> WELL, I THINK WE STILL DO
HAVE SOME BUT CLEARLY NOT WHAT
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY WITH OUR
TROOPS THERE AND WITH OUR
MISSION, YOU KNOW, OUR EMBASSY
THERE.
BUT I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE MISSION,
THE MISSION WAS TO PREVENT THAT
IT AREA, AFGHANISTAN FROM BEING
USED AS A TERRORIST LAUNCHING
SITE.
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
AND, AGAIN, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
REALITY ON THE GROUND AND SAY
THAT THERE ARE AMERICANS THERE,
THERE ARE A LOT OF AMERICANS
APPARENTLY OUT OF THAT 250 WHO
CHOOSE TO BE THERE MOST OF THOSE
THAT ARE LEFT THERE IN TERMS THE
AFGHANS ARE PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
GET OUT BUT WE JUST COULDN'T
MANAGE IT AND I THINK THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS AND YOU LOOK AT
FOUR PRESIDENTS, BRET, YOU LOOK
AT PRESIDENT BUSH WHO CHOSE TO
GO IN THERE, AND DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO GET OUT.
YOU LOOK AT PRESIDENT OBAMA, YOU
KNOW, HE PUT MORE TROOPS IN BUT
IT WAS LIKE A BAND-AID.
HE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO GET
OUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEGOTIATED WITH
THE TALIBAN, THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
AND NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN UNDER
ESTIMATED THE STRENGTH OF THE
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF MISTAKES
HERE.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, TREY, LAST
WORD.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO PROCESS
HOW AFGHANISTAN IS NO LONGER A
LAUNCHING SITE FOR TERRORISM
WITH THE 13 COFFINS THAT I SAW
AT DOVER AIR FORCE BASE
APPARENTLY IT STILL IS A
LAUNCHING PAD FOR TERRORISM
BECAUSE 13 OF OUR SOLDIERS WERE
KILLED WITHIN THE PAST WEE